kannst hier mal das video jetzt einen
gleichen aparte bleibt gleich würde im
club ist habe ich das auch hast du
gesagt kann ich habe es nur ich hoffe
mal dann bin ich sein natürlich will ich
[Musik]
es nicht mehr so viele
ich freue mich vielleicht schafft man
das dieses jahr noch etwas gibt und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
ja dich auch natürlich geht es gut ich
wollte nur mal kurz also man muss sagen
ich habe schon ewig nicht mehr so eigene
klamotten gemacht oder so am 16.12 gibt
viele was von mir und zwar unter anderem
diesen schuh holly hinten fehlt auch
noch was drauf weitere infos geben wir
euch noch also an alle die interesse
haben vielleicht würde mich sehr freuen
schreibt hinter die ohren 16 dazu
erklärt also ich wollte ihn jetzt schon
mal aber ich muss sagen der polizei ich
selber naja
deswegen steht ihr wahrscheinlich auf
einer ecke jetzt vielleicht irgendwo
werbung oder so es kann sein junger satz
ich muss mir auf den sitzen
es kann sein dass einige jetzt wieder
meckern werden weil es ja schon wieder
irgendwas mit kopfhörern ist das tut mir
auch ein bisschen leid
morgen gibt es versprochen wieder ein
ganz anderes video und 9 kommt ein
heftiges video was machen wir morgen
wollen kaufen ein neues handy und
schmeißen es in den media markt
automaten und gucken was er uns gibt ob
wir kratzen verluste waren meist oder
aber heute geht es nicht um irgendwelche
airport fakes oder sonstiges ich habe
mir das irgendwann mal wirklich so ich
dachte es gibt so viel zeug auf markt du
musst doch mal was anderes testen
und deswegen bin ich gerade hier an
diese dinger gekommen
wir können ja gerne mal du kannst ja
gern mal drauf film das sind die elf
neuen tws
[Musik]
habe ich bestellt oder ich sage mal so
umsonst bekommen deswegen muss sich
jetzt leider ab jetzt es tut mir sehr
leid ich hoffe ihr nehmt es mir nicht
böse immer hier in die ecke mit irgendwo
werbevideo schreiben weil sonst könnte
ich so ein paar probleme kriegen ich
kann das ja vielleicht noch mal ganz
kurz ganz schnell erklären ein kollege
von mir er hat seinen eigenen job
gemacht wo er halt solche produkte
anbietet also ganz viel was ich
eigentlich in meinen videos thematisiere
und er gibt mir alles was ich haben will
was ich immer videos testen möchte
umsonst ich kann es für euch testen und
das ist praktisch für alles gerade bei
so airport sachen dann muss ich nicht
immer kaufen weil ich habe schon so viel
geld dafür in sand gesetzt also was
heißt den sand gesetzt natürlich ist
auch mein geschäftsmodell
wir fangen jetzt mal an wir machen das
erst mal auf so und zweige werdet schon
direkt sehen das produkt verlinkt sich
natürlich auch in der video beschreibung
guck mal hier das ist diesmal das case
dann haben wir hier noch us pcs richtig
wird und auch so konfus und ja das
wichtigste ist aber natürlich dass hier
ich muss sagen ich hab selber schon mal
reingeguckt es gibt auch im internet
viele dieser kopfhörer allerdings habe
ich gedacht das könnte einer der besten
sein und habe den halt mir deswegen
ausgesucht hatte sogar rezensionen und
man sieht ja schon
also ich wollte mal was anderes mal hier
die folie noch ab eine folie war auch
nur auf keinem brauche ab und zu mal
aber nicht so viel kann man auch glaube
ich ganz gut hier in die taschen stecken
ist natürlich ein bisschen besser als
airports das muss man sagen aber
beschreibung ist auftritt und was haben
die gekostet gute frage ich glaube die
kosten kann also ja mal einen kann ich
genau ich bin es euch hier mal ein ich
meine 29 euro würden die kosten
irgendwie so mannschaft und ich habe
natürlich verfolgt für dich da freu mich
das erste mal so eigentlich war es ein
gut ich habe in der vergangenheit schon
öfter mal was umsonst bekommen aber die
airport videos sind eigentlich alle also
90 prozent meiner videos habe ich alles
selber gekauft okay da ich mache jetzt
mal aufgemacht
so sind die aus also kommt auch schon an
ist halt wirklich mal was anderes da
muss ich jetzt sagen ich bin total
gespannt ob die vom sound her weiß wir
haben jetzt hier 29
zahlt die 1000 ews bis jetzt ja der
absolute favorit von mir gibt es glaube
ich im internet so zwischen 25 und 30
euro sind von der qualität auf jeden
fall gut und wir schauen wir auf die
schlagen können ich würde sagen ich hol
dir mal raus soll ich dir auch mit mit
airports verein brauche ich eigentlich
nicht oder
das haben jetzt schon so oft gemacht
irgendwann reicht's sommer oder soll ich
zumindest mal kurz im case holen sind
wir von der größe halten oder
verschieben weil das sieht schon nicht
so krass handlich aus
auf den ersten blick die große wahl des
airports pro case das war ja auch groß
ja das nennen das war ungefähr so also
wir haben ja schon unterschied da muss
man ganz klar sagen das ist ein kleiner
negativer punkt dass hier also dick sind
aber man kann sie sie in die tasche
stecken habe hier getestet und solange
die vom sound herrn eis sind ist ja
alles gut dann kann man das hier auch
wieder vergessen so ich muss mal ganz
kurz hier auf die beschreibung schauen
wir haben auch natürlich so ein touch
control dingen integriert music playing
teil vier bis fünf stunden aufladezeit
ein bis zwei stunden
das gilt jetzt ob wir sind jetzt auch
und was aber interessantes die halten
temperaturen bis minus 55 grad celsius
aus uns im wasserdicht das heißt
theoretisch kann so weit komme mir um
die airports von und auch wasserdicht
damit vom nordpol mehrere hören ja wo
sind auch wasserdicht aber habe ich gar
nicht gepasst das hätte ich mal machen
sollen na ja die ganzen tws wächst
allerdings nicht deswegen theoretisch
könnte ich mit denen gleich mal kurz
duschen ich wollte gleich acht mal genau
die dresdner nach oben
die adresse sowie bei der hübschen dame
hier auf einem bild oder das stelle ich
mir hängen ich mir über mein bett wenn
ich dieses video nicht schlecht aus von
marie kommt reingeflogen bösen kann man
machen oder oder ehrlich wir galten als
tourist im vergleich ist sie halt nicht
raus das aber auch nicht schlecht und
die hängen gar nicht raus also die kann
man auf jedenfalls für mich drin stecken
so privat immer ich glaube jetzt sind
wenn man einmal drin hat dann fällt da
links auf das was viele alte spieler
also ich bin auf jeden fall vom sound
her sehr gut abgeschottet von der us
version
so die steckt man einfach ins ohr und
ich hoffe der connected sich jetzt hier
ok also im moment mal ich bin jetzt hier
direkt connected f9 heißen die damals
sicher ganz gut merken hier einmal für
euch
und jetzt da ohne scheiß man muss ja
sagen das sind die ersten die es so
aussehen
ich bin wirklich gespannt ob der ton ob
der neiße ist dann musst du natürlich
auch nicht mehr rein hat kannst hier mal
das video jetzt einen blick nach vorn
bleibt vielleicht für den klub ist habe
ich das auch alles gesagt ich hab's noch
ich hoffe mal dann bin ich natürlich für
dich also wie lange auf jeden fall immer
eine stimme ziemlich viel am anfang muss
man sagen aber jetzt jetzt ist es alles
eingerichtet
[Musik]
ich hatte am anfang kurze probleme weil
der hat irgend wieder aufgehört muss ich
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen aber ich
glaube das war damals die mit touch
control warum ist da draußen
krankenwagen wir drehen doch gerade mein
gott ich glaube das lag an weil ich dann
mit touch control ausgemacht habe dann
hab ich nämlich noch mal drauf gedrückt
dann nimmt er wieder an vom sound muss
ich aber sagen sind die echt richtig gut
die haben leider keinen smart sensor
also die laufen durch gehen weiter er
ist gut jetzt hier sind aber vom sound
ja auf jeden fall besser als 2008 mit
zwei andere probieren diesen deshalb
zielten auf jeden fall ohne scheiß dafür
dass du selbst wirklich soll das ist
eigentlich so gut hier hast du
wahrscheinlich auch mehr platz drin um
irgendwelche technik zu verbauen
links zu julias jetzt gerade drin ja
ganz gut
also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich
hatte eben leichte connection probleme
jetzt ist alles wohl gefixed und der
sound ist wirklich top ich halte ich mag
ist wenn man die dinge sich so rein ins
ohr und muss aber vom sound herberts
macht mich total dass markt also ich sag
mal so für 29 euro kann man nicht
meckern jetzt mal unter die dusche und
ein telefoniere ich mit dem ok und dann
denken wir dass man erwarten kann
wir gucken ob das war noch mal ein
bisschen extra es in der beschreibung
städte sind absolut wasserdicht ja also
leicht auf jeden fall noch kein halt
auch ehrlicherweise neben wasser
eindringen deswegen wird glaube ich dass
das was hier wirklich wasserdicht sind
wahrscheinlich kannst du mit den jetzt
nicht ganz viel wenn deutschland 1000 so
wie ich das mache beim auftauchen meiste
aber förmlich vielleicht auch so von
hier noch rufe ich bringe mal kurz durch
ja ja ja ich würde ich sag mal eben aber
die quali ist so mittel also ich finde
es jetzt nicht so über krass aber auch
jetzt nicht total schlecht also ist okay
das war okay war okay ich würde sagen da
sind vielleicht die 1000 ews ein
bisschen besser kommt also mikrofon und
ich weiß jetzt nicht so ok halber markus
best sound richtig gut ist eines der
beste also sonst haut führen 29 finde
ich das telefonat war so sehr gut und
verbindung war am ende auf jeden fall da
am anfang hatten wir leichte problem
muss ich sagen also sind gute dinge kann
ich empfehlen
ich habe euch also ich habe meinen
kollegen aus eschborn oder hat mir noch
so einen gutscheincode gegeben könnt ihr
euch ja gerne mal den shop anschauen ist
ein deutscher shop mit deutschen support
ich habe das ganze operative steuerung
verlinkt ich habe ja gestern so airport
cases getestet die waren unter anderem
auch man da vielleicht hat der eine oder
andere von euch schon mal reingeschaut
ansonsten
ich will das auch gar nicht zu viel
haben wir sehen uns morgen um 19 uhr
wieder abonniert alle den kanal rating
one million
es fehle nicht mehr so viele ich freue
mich vielleicht schafft man das dieses
jahr noch und ich geh jetzt mal wirklich
gruseln bds dran geblieben sind haben
glück und zwar habe ich von ihm zwei
dinger bekommen schreibt einfach mal
einen kommentar mit eurem instagram
hierunter das video mit der karotte
kontaktieren gewinner einer woche und
tippt dann halt diese beiden gegner aus
oder ihr kauft euch die jetzt von dem
kopf leute leute das war rein
[Musik]